it is great to welcome ray comfort back
onto the program the filmmaker of the
atheist delusion ray and I have had a
number of I guess I would characterize
them as and lightning and compelling
conversations over the years uh ray
talked to it what's the goal when you do
a film like the atheist delusion and you
know we've talked about a number of the
films you've done a lot of them involve
interviewing people on the street these
don't necessarily always seem like the
most sort of politically savvy or aware
folks and I sometimes wonder whether
you're cherry-picking and taking
advantage of people I'm guessing you'll
you'll say that you're not doing that
but what's the goal when you make a film
like the Atheist delusion this is the
same with obviously David thank you for
having me on the show
honors it yeah you want me back and I do
appreciate it
the goal with everything we do is to say
hey we're found everlasting life we're
110% convinced of it and we want to
share it with everyone including
atheists so I've been I've been living
with that agenda for 44 years every
moment of my time every ounce of energy
I've got I want to say death has been
destroyed
everlasting life as a free gift of God
if you're a pen trust him every simple
message and it just gets wrapped up in
different things cherry-picking
now we chose the most intelligent
atheists we could find yeah I mean
obviously anybody who watches and we'll
be linking to the film will well I think
question that because you're you're
mostly picking people who with your as
you like to say and you did this with
the the abortion documentary that we
discuss over whose name which is name
escapes me right now and I apologize 180
180 right and you're doing it here with
the idea of a belief in God give us the
sort of frame up the question that you
like to use which I like to call it the
designed and designer question how is it
that you are able to convince these
atheists to believe that God exists well
I went to make a video for one of my
publishers on a book called made in
heaven a very comprehensible with
full-color pictures and I met an atheist
named Adam of all names and Adam was
very nice and I gave him the book and I
said do you think this book could have
happened by accident the ink fell from
the sky and formed itself into color
pictures and coherent sentences and then
more ink fell from the sky and form
itself and a page
numbers in sequential order bound itself
and made itself into a book could a book
make itself is it absolutely not that's
ridiculous and then they said what's DNA
and we talked about DNA being called a
book by scientist the book of life and
how it's full of comprehensive
information programming and then I said
DNA makes the book I put on your lap
seem feeble it's so comprehensive so
much information so much programming I
said what was you thinking the
intelligence is someone who thought a
physical book can make itself he said
there'd be an idiot and so what do you
think of the intelligence does somebody
believe DNA made itself and suddenly he
saw the foolishness of atheism it's
absolutely impossible for DNA to make
itself it's beyond the realm of
possibility so that's the question I ask
them and they're all intelligent people
especially Haley uh the elder are
brunette she was brilliant and so to say
us cherry-picking is just not true well
with yet the fact that you you're citing
two people that were smart doesn't mean
that you were or weren't cherry-picking
who knows how many people you
interviewed who knows how long the
interviews went on I don't think that's
proof for a defense of anything but what
I want to focus on is the sort of
argument right uh you you're what you're
talking basically is about because there
was a design there must be a designer
but the problem is that something being
complex doesn't necessarily require a
designer but I think the more
interesting question is that there's
something called the watchmakers
argument which you you're I'm sure
familiar with and maybe some in our
audience are you look at a watch and you
say wow that's complex so someone must
have designed it right well yes the
watchmaker designed it but the
watchmaker is far more complex than the
watch so who designed the watchmaker
well you would say God and God certainly
is far more complex than the watchmaker
so who designed God it's like being on a
plane and some guy sitting next you
inside the plane had no maker and I say
that's ridiculous to say the plane had
no maker to think that everything fell
together and suddenly sees the
foolishness of an argument instead of
conceding and saying yeah that makes
sense there must've been a maker he says
okay who made the maker of the plane it
just changes the subject and that's all
that is this is this may be the
watchmaker argument to some but to
compare a watch
- biological DNA is like comparing
apples with elephants well but hold on a
second red you're taking issue with
comparing a watch to DNA forty five
seconds earlier you compared a book to
DNA in order to convince Adam that
atheism doesn't make sense so how is it
any different you don't like that I'm
comparing a watch to DNA but you compare
a book to DNA to say how stupid it is to
think a watch or a book can make itself
compared to DNA DNA is in Krita is
deoxyribonucleic acid right designs your
eyes your ears your blood your skin you
hear your personality everything was in
your DNA from the moment you were
conceived and compare it to an inanimate
watch you know my friend the Friendly
Atheist did the watchmaking comparison
and on his on his same argument in the
comments and a theist said that's you
can't compare a watch to biological DNA
is that it's just there's no comparison
that was right but then why did you
compare it to a book is what I'm
confused about - so he'll show how
stupid it is to compare it to a book
because a book is an animal and if a
book can't make itself how much more
can't DNA make itself there's a
comparison and the watch is nothing like
DNA they are comparisons and so I'm not
saying it's the same as a book I'm
saying it's ridiculous to think a book
and make itself right seriously David
did you think a book made itself yes I
did you think I don't think a book made
its up but the problem is that you're
saying okay well the book can make
itself so the bookmaker clearly made the
book and the book maker was of course
created by DNA which was designed by God
are you go up up up but your designer
analogy stops with God because as you've
told me before God Jesus Christ I don't
want to put words in your mic in your
mouth however you like to describe it uh
is the all-knowing and all-powerful will
but then who created God why do you stop
your analogy of taking steps up this
sort of I don't stop the ALS god David
it's just that every atheist of us who
may God doesn't put a question mark at
the end of it they put an explanation
point no I'm asking I'm putting a
question mark on the end of it very
simple I tell I've done thousands of
times I've explained that God didn't
have a maker he's eternal he's without
the realm of time look I don't think I'm
alone
I can't understand GPS I'm driving my
car south in California
hundreds of thousands of cars all around
suddenly it's a woman I don't know
speaks to me and says I've detected
traffic ahead I've rerouted you to save
you four minutes and I say well who are
you lady why'd you do this for me do you
do it for everybody
I don't know how she does it I wouldn't
have a clue well that's because you
don't know much about GPS and have an
acute violent finished haven't finished
if I can't understand GPS how could I
ever understand the the turn allottee of
God I can't understand the eternality of
God I can't imagine a realm outside of
time but time is created by God you and
I subjected to it we have to wait till
time passes God is outside the realm
that he created it it's very simple we
accept that he that the space has no
beginning an end you think space has an
end
the strange thing though ray and I
really I want to try to understand this
so I can really see where you're coming
from I don't understand how you can use
as an argument but the book didn't make
itself the book maker made the book the
watch didn't make itself the watch maker
made the watch DNA didn't make itself
God made DNA however God which you say
trance you know transcends time and
space and is so eternal and complex and
we can't possibly understand it
something infinitely more complex than a
watch or DNA or a book nothing made that
that doesn't really make sense I don't
think that will resonate with many in
our audience it doesn't matter well I
know it doesn't matter a video yeah it
doesn't matter to me because there's a
lot of things that don't make sense
we're in a big bowl spinning through
space
you know thousand miles an hour and the
son sitting raised 93 million miles and
and all the stuff doesn't really make
sense but we accept it sorry says no
beginning and no end doesn't make sense
it's gotta have an end it doesn't and so
we just accept there by faith and do the
same thing with with the tonality of God
tonality of God you'll say okay don't
understand it but I trust it alright
well I think we've gotten sort of as far
as we can at least in figuring out where
you are on this issue here's something
else that I want to know about just from
seeing a number of your films now you
sometimes say that many people who claim
they are atheists know in their hearts
that God is real but they don't even
wanna
it to themselves sometimes because they
like porn and sex too much and sometimes
you actually dig into people's sexual
habits in you Assam relatively specific
questions about that what's the deal
like why is that interesting to you or I
guess the real question for our audience
maybe is what broader point would we
what would be more broadly learn by
talking to people about whether they
like porn or sex or sexual habits David
I don't dig into people's sexual habits
I have some of that fornicated if they
watch pornography it's as simple as that
okay bring out the fact that it's a
moral issue not it's not an intellectual
issue you know God exists I know God
exists but we deny the truth we suppress
it and righteousness now you can deny
that but I've got the instruction book
that tells me all about you
you're made by godly yes absolutely
you're a human being you're made in the
image of God you've got a conscience you
know right from wrong you're separate
from the animals you're not a beast
you're made in God's image with a
knowledge of right and wrong okay but
now that relate to watching porn oh
because we love darkness rather than
light the Bible says it's a moral issue
we can't find God for the same reason a
thief can't find a policeman the last
thing you ever want to find out is if
God exists and he's watching everything
you do he holds you accountable and
there's a genuine judgement dan is a
reality of hell you don't want to know
that he'll exists so you deny the truth
then you carry on and join the places of
sin I've been where you are and I mean
every person who's become a Christian
says yeah that I knew the truth but I
denied it I suppress it I love the
darkness hate the light and when I come
to it do you think we give them at least
we're atheists could watch can we say
we're the atheist could watch the
atheist delusion I watched it on YouTube
what's the official place for people to
age yeah atheist movie calm oh yes movie
calm love to know what I see atheist
think we put it out there for you guys
to watch and well I think you know a lot
of what they think I mean I think most a
thien's atheist find it pretty
unconvincing yeah yeah well I'm not out
to convince atheists I'm out to convince
the millions that are on the fence and
saying is there evidence of God's
existence though absolutely there's
scientific evidence watch this movie the
atheist whose fundamental hard-nosed he
won't watch it I didn't see evidence a
scientific evidence of God's existence
in the
movie and I watched it but hey let me
ask you this do you believe that you and
I have spoken a number of times now
you've never told me specifically that
I'm going to hell but I know it's
something that that that's a concern to
you do you believe that eventually I
will find what you consider to be the
right path is that something you believe
oh it's my sincere hope you've seen Penn
Jillette's video on on hell no I have
seen him talk about that it's absolutely
incredible Penn Jillette atheist more
committed probably than you he crosses
out and God We Trust well I'm not
committed to atheism I mean is it to be
very clear I just have not seen any
reason to think that there is what would
be described as a sort of personal God
the man in the sky etcetera I really
rarely think about atheism to be honest
so to say I believe in me let me finish
the pain to let quote if I may David
because and we'll digress he said this
he says if you're a Christian and you
really believe that Heaven and Hell
exist how much do you have to hate
someone not to warn them not to tell
them about it right and that's so true
if I see a truck hitting mean this is
what Penn Jillette said if a truck was
bearing down on you and you didn't know
what the time would come where I would
tackle you
that's what Penn Jillette and he says
and this is more important and my whole
reason the passion that I've got now is
only because I know that every hour 6000
people die every day
150,000 every year 54 million you're
going to die it could be in a second
could be tonight could be tomorrow it
could be 50 years who knows God knows
and I want you to find everlasting life
I don't want you to find God's justice
man it terrifies me to think you could
die in your sins and I love you and I
care about you even though you don't
realize that and that's my motive I'm
accused of making money and look I could
have made a lot of money mining my own
business I started my business one it's
20 right I left it to do this so you're
saying that any attacks on your your
sort of intentions here is being
financially motivated you just want to
save people from hell I want to see
people say from hell I can't save anyone
but the Savior can Rea where are you on
Trump versus Clinton we've had these
election results is this even something
you think about or I mean is Trump
seemed like a godly man to you is he a
good Christian oh no no no I don't it
doesn't seem like a godly man but you
see the issue to me
isn't isn't fiscal it's not fiscal but
the whole issue comes down to abortion
yeah Hillary Clinton believed you could
partially birth a baby let the head out
and then kill it and drag it out and
that's fine it's a woman yeah she never
saw no reply done such right if she did
she said she believes that a baby right
up until this born doesn't have rights
as a human being and that's partial
birth abortion well that's ik when that
Lyra license isn't it yeah yeah that's
right and that that terrifies me so
that's the only concern I have yeah and
I'm not out to judge Trump or Hillary
but if she says she believes in any form
of abortion I'm horrified not ever vote
for someone that believes like that but
so but even in spite of Donald Trump
claiming to be pro-life in spite of
being pro-choice his entire life you
still say that he's not godly what else
is it is it the fact that he holds his
own book the art of the deal to the same
esteem as the Bible or is it something
else
well you know someone by their fruit so
someone's loving and kind and
compassionate good then you know they're
a Christian if they if they if they're
not then you know they're not and our
church is a full of people who play the
hypocrite but I'm not out to judge
Donald Trump Trump he has to answer to
God and and and he seems to be slowing
down and as rhetoric so that's a that's
a good sign did you vote Trump I don't
know if you vote here in the US it's not
a people business David only God and I
know what I voted and my wife uh okay
well listen ray it's always fascinating
I do want people to check out the
atheist delusion I was completely
unconvinced by it and found it to be you
know basically just talking to not that
informed people and asking them uh very
particularly worded questions in order
to elicit a response but there may be
others who see it differently and I
would love to hear frege's a something
there is intelligent as you that's what
I believe that well I know that that is
an attack on me more than it is anything
else but no it's not a compliment to you
I think you're intelligent guy and they
were intelligent Ray counsel Rd crafts
the film is the atheist illusion
Lawrence Krauss is interviewed a guy
we've interviewed many many times ray
it's always great to talk to you thank
you thank you sir